foreign
[Music]
spectator show in which we take another
look at the week's news and what else is
there really to talk about this week
other than Gary lineker and his spat
with the BBC uh it has dominated the
headlines for the last few days and
seems to have been resolved today on
Monday with the news that Gary lineker
has won effectively he is now allowed to
tweet whatever he wants about whatever
he wants and he will continue he will go
back to
hosting match of the day which he did
not do on Saturday night my name is
Freddie gray I'm the deputy header and
spectator and I'm joined Now by Damien
Riley who is a spectator online
contributor and columnist
and Damian you wrote an excellent piece
over the weekend saying we're finding
out the headline was we're finding out
who runs the BBC
uh and I think the answer it seems is uh
Gary lineker and the people behind Gary
lineker not uh the people who paid the
license fee or the director General even
all chairman of the BBC well exactly
that's exactly right and I think it's
why the whole thing blew up so fast I
think we uh on the face of it it was an
issue about whether Garland could tweet
uh politically or not but I think it it
erupted into something much larger than
that which was
a report on where we are in the culture
War and who really runs the BBC and
whether it is the people who pay for it
which is the license Pairs and the
management of the BBC which is the Dutch
General and the chairman or whether it
is the so-called talent and uh it turns
out they are in charge
well so let's talk about the leadership
of the BBC because obviously Boris
Johnson tried to change the culture at
the BBC he brought in Tim Davey director
general or team David came in under his
watch uh he also was in charge of
Richard Sharp becoming the chairman and
that's quite controversial because
Richard shelv of course gave him a loan
which does make his position fairly
ridiculous and what's noticeable is
these two figures have been very quiet
and it seems they've caved in fact Gary
lineker thanked Davey today for uh being
so supportive over the last few days so
they've they've backed down and
essentially well it looked for a while
it looked quite promising so if you
promising you mean as a very unusual
word well promising in terms of it
looked like because there are a long
time people have been saying there is a
lot a big lack of impartiality at the
BBC particularly under the previous
regime and under uh Tim Davey there does
seem to have been an exodus of people
who were doing a very bad job of
disguising their political views and
were unable to at least affect
neutrality and seen people like Emily
maitless John sopel there was good old
Nish Kumar Andrew ma all departed and so
it looked as if the BBC was making a big
play towards impartiality and making
sure that people within the organization
at least publicly pretended to be
impartial but it seems with the
galiniker issue that that is uh that is
that all of that good work is completely
lost now the precedent has been set from
now on anybody within the BBC who is
told that tweet is a bit impartial you
seem to be making clear your your
politics online it can just point to the
guardianica precedent and say sue me
let's talk about the Free Speech aspect
of this debate because uh it may be a
little bit stale but it's still been a
major part of the conversation I mean
why can't Gary lineke have free speech
on Twitter why do you think he is a
football presenter can't air his views
on my the migrant crisis on the Tories
whatever he wants
I suppose there's several ways to answer
that question I think it's not that
important that he is a sports presenter
I think he's a BBC employee and
therefore uh he is bound by the rule of
impartiality that should uh
bind all in BBC employees
the first thing to say is that garlic is
a very privileged position he has 8.8
million Twitter followers and that is a
directly attributable to his position at
the BBC he has the plum job presenting
match today they say if you're going to
talk about the you know the best way to
uh the best thing that can happen for
ideas is they get put in the public
sphere and people can debate them and
they can live or die based on that but
Gary doesn't really do that he just sort
of lobs them on on Twitter
to his followers he doesn't appear on
question time and take part in debates
about the things he he believes
um I suppose that doesn't really answer
the question why can't he do it I think
the broader point is the that the BBC is
distinguished
um from other news organizations
throughout the world by its impartiality
and as soon as you lose that it's lost
forever it will never be got back and
the precedent is set but would you
Damien Riley as a few people have made
this point and I think it may have some
validity uh would you Damien Riley if uh
let's say I can out you as a pro-brexit
person now uh if
um
Gary lineker had tweeted something along
the lines of great that the government's
getting this situation under control
with the boats this is something we can
do now that we've left
uh the European Union and there'd been a
huge hoo-ha about that and everybody on
the left had said unacceptable for him
would you have how would you feel about
that would you say he'd breached his
impartiality do you think yes I would
think he's in breached his impartiality
I mean it's very easy to say yeah no you
wouldn't you'd be able to Manning the
barricades defending him yeah but no
it's it's wrong they shouldn't that none
of them also I mean the bare fact that
they have huge audiences and if you
start airing political views you're
going to antagonize people and also he
does know that he's deliberately saying
provocative things so you can't have all
surprise when people are provoked and
get angry
um do you think I mean a lot of Tories
now or right-wingers are saying what
this whole situation what this whole
crisis over the weekend has pointed
towards is that the taxpayer-funded
model the license fee model of the BBC
is dysfunctional in the modern media
environment it doesn't work to have
you're never going to be able to to you
know keep every able to use employed at
the BBC or has a profile at the BBC
you're never going to be able to keep
their views silent because of social
media uh should we just get rid of this
pretense that it's a sort of semi-state
body yeah so I don't follow that
argument at all I saw Jacob Bruce MOG
making it and I think there are certain
elements of the Tory party particularly
which will always enjoy bashing the BBC
and threatening the license being model
I don't also believe that you can't keep
people quiet because of social media I
think there is a kite there is a problem
within the BBC of near uniform uh near
uniformity of Outlook so they talk about
inclusivity and diversity all the time
um but I don't think there is diversity
of
thought I think there's a great deal of
diversity probably of skin color and all
the other types of diversity but there
isn't there's a sort of uniformity of
Outlook and I think they should Rectify
that as quickly as possible let's turn
the conversation back towards lineaker
because that's what people really really
like talking about and it seems to me a
lot of people like talking about it
because while he has a lot of fans 8.8
million followers on Twitter I'm not
sure all of them like him but uh
certainly there seems to be a lot of
people who are pro Gary and his right to
speak
um he's also quite divisive a lot of
people since brexit particularly where
he's been very uh vocal about brexit uh
he obviously thinks it's an awful thing
and he said quite a lot against it
um on Twitter there's a large section of
the public that supports brexit or just
it finds it annoying when they're
lectured about brexit uh that find him
obnoxious and smug and irritating and I
would say I find him obnoxious and smug
and irritating when he talks about
football as well I actually just don't I
just think it's my obnoxious and yeah I
mean well it was the the the Qatar uh
Speech he gave at the beginning of the
World Cup Qatar and I know the BBC
signed off on that but I thought it was
a ridiculous way to start the World Cup
and you could almost see in his eyes as
he gave it he was thinking about all the
the sort of retweets and likes he was
getting he's become one of those people
who's been possibly further ruined or
ruined by social media and he's addicted
to the likes and the retweets and the
sense of validation he gets about his
opinions because there are a lot of
people who will validate them do you
think his bigger problem is that he's a
divisive figure now and that as a major
as the face of BBC sport in many ways
not just the presenter of match of the
day
he is unpopular
no I don't I think we live in divided
times everything is so polarized now
um from brexit to other parts of the
culture where people everything has
become so polarized and that's why it's
so stupid of him to get involved with
these political tweets because you he's
very obviously going to antagonize half
of his audience
um I think just talking about football
uh is he's completely fine he's sort of
a few weak puns you know she's a film
it's not exactly rocket science somebody
said I totally agree with it that Mr
Blobby presenting match today would
still draw the same audiences people
don't turn up to watch Gary lineker
they're turning up to watch the football
uh nicely edited and that's not really
it's amazing that he gets paid 1.35
million quid to do that did you watch
match today on Saturday uh I've watched
a little bit of it yeah I saw it I mean
I watched it and it seems to me it had
it had a much higher audience 2.58
million probably a lot of people tuning
in just out of curiosity to see what it
would look like
um but it was very boiled down to just
to Highlights there was no theme tune
there was no analysis there was no
commentary uh I don't think I do think
probably it's a better show with some
analysis uh not it doesn't necessarily
have to be by linica no far from it but
I guess that showed the power of
the talent that they were managed they
managed to to scare everybody away from
the program so it was quite an
astonishing show of power that lineker
first of all was withdrawn and then I
think Ian Wright and Alan Shearer said
they wouldn't do it and then all the
commentators from the game said they
wouldn't do it yeah and then uh some of
the other pundits that they wouldn't
step in and then I what I thought was
really amazing was Piers Morgan tweeted
anyone thinking of doing this we will
see you and we will judge you and I
thought that was a real show of power
that was no no no mucking around anyone
think of doing this as in getting
involved in anyone thinking of
presenting the show yeah you said I
think these AdWords where we will see
you and we will judge you yeah it's like
okay speaking of Gary lineker's
likability I thought his tweet this
morning was particularly amazing uh a
particularly good example of the sort of
divisiveness we're talking about he said
after he'd sort of said that he was
coming back on he said a final thought
it wasn't actually his final thought he
had a few more but a final thought
however difficult the last few days have
been it simply doesn't compare to having
to Fleet your home from persecution or
Ward seek refuge in a land far away it's
heartwarming to have seen the empathy
towards their plight from so many of you
what's your reaction to that do you
think good for Gary for being so humble
and seeing the bigger picture or do you
think what an obnoxious Prat I think for
that I think very much the latter I
think
it is the reason that why the
impartiality is so crucial fundamentally
is that it is so easy to start saying my
opinions are steeped in the milk of
human kindness and therefore can only be
viewed as utterly right even though
they're impartial it's right so I
believe these migrants coming over
illegally and risking their lives must
all be good people a terrible risk and
anybody who thinks they shouldn't come
over illegally is a Nazi and so you move
move the halfway line and the debate if
it's a big football pitch in the debate
on what's important impartial and what's
not you move it
incrementally a few inches towards I
suppose the lib Outlook yeah at the cost
of of everyone else and and those the
gains that are made in the cultural are
never given back and I think it's a
really good example of it what do you
mean by that the games and the culture
will never give back so I think it's
what we're seeing so I think about when
I started in journalism I started at
Reuters and we used to argue everyone in
The Newsroom used to argue if some
somebody blew up a Bus full of children
and somebody would write the story
saying terrorist blows up Bus full of
children and other people say well no
it's not he's not a terrorist he's
terrorists depending on your Viewpoint
to other people he's a freedom fighter
and so there was a big so that's how
seriously they took this sort of
impartiality
and I think Reuters now capitalizes the
word black out of respect even that
makes no grammatical sense they
capitalize it out of respect some sort
of politically correct respect to the
oppression subjugation black people have
gone through over the years so it's a
sort of example of of the work mindset
getting taking over what is meant to be
a totally impartial news organization
much like BBC and that is that is an
incremental gain in the cultural War
it's a taking of land that can never be
given back because to then de-capitalize
the word black is is to say well what
you know it's a huge argument yes and I
think it's exactly what's happening with
linica this route it's not really about
linica it's about trying to move where
the line of impartiality is and whether
we need to be impartial anymore and I
think as soon as you've lost that you've
lost the essence of the BBC and
everything it stands for everything will
crumble quite quickly after that so
because you know because people now know
everybody now knows that Gary lineker
who presents match of the day thinks
that the government's position on boats
and the language it uses is reminiscent
of the 1930s to use the exact you didn't
use the word Nazi okay but because
everybody now knows that people think
that that's that's the right opinion
you're saying
like no I think it's bigger than that I
think it's just saying we don't need to
bother with impartiality anymore and as
soon as you the idea the fact is that
what he said with the road to hell is
paved with good intentions yeah so
Gallant is probably a lovely guy despite
you know and uh thinks he's doing a
lovely thing and he he thinks these poor
people the terrible things happening to
them but of course there's a much much
more complex argument uh and there are a
lot of people that would say his opinion
is a hundred percent wrong and that it's
enabling people smuggling and women and
children who are trapped in the rubble
in Ukraine would like to get asylum in
the UK are getting you know put to the
back of the cube because all these legal
albanians are coming over whatever
doesn't the internet aren't that
important
um what I think is
the impartiality is is there to prevent
people through the best of intentions
getting things wrong so but do you think
just in terms of public perceptions
whatever about the debate I mean I'd say
that well lineker has won the right to
tweet whatever he wants I think most
people have come down on the side of
thinking that actually comparing this
government to the Nazis about this
difficult moral question of what we do
about the boats
uh I'd say most people have have come
down on the side of the government in
the sense that they don't agree that
linica should have said that they think
you should have the right set but they
don't agree should have said it so in a
sense you know sunlight is the best
disinfectant and and having had this
public conversation well I don't know it
doesn't really matter am I supposed to
take that on you would say so they're
now talking about having a review of
BBC's use of social media in both these
employees so just say uh all BBC
employees allowed to tweet whatever they
like or maybe ones that don't work in
news but working you know DJs or
presenters elsewhere I suppose what we
will see if they do want to start
treating their genuine political beliefs
is the uniformity of of belief and their
political attitudes and maybe that will
bring about some change but it is
fundamentally very dull to hear people's
political opinions yes if you you know
maybe certain indeed I listen to Zoe
ball in the mornings if I find out that
she's an Ardent uh
I mean it's highly unlikely but say she
she thought it was absolutely burning
imperative that Boris Johnson was
reinstated as prime minister and she
tweeted that every day yeah if I I was
like I don't want to hear that from her
I want to order climate change yeah
anything like that you're like that's
there's a time and place for that it's
not uh you these platforms they've got
are the result their social media
there's no two ways around it there's no
so there's no way around it the social
media platforms are the result of their
BBC positions BBC positions are paid for
by us and therefore they don't think
they should be used for in matters of
impartiality will you be tuning in to
match today on Saturday night
uh probably not I don't know do
something amazing it was actually a
particularly weak uh set of highlights I
thought generally right so it was a bit
I mean it's impressive that they got
2.58 million because they weren't any
particularly impressive games would be
quite interesting to see how long people
people got to the end I imagine people
just tuned in at the start to see to see
what Clinica wasn't there do you think
lastly David do you think the problem
might be that we don't really want to
hear from football as the next
footballers about politics because they
don't actually have a I mean I don't I
think I know Gary linekers runs the rest
is history podcast
uh he owns the company that runs it uh
but I don't think he's a renowned
scholar of the Third Reich so I don't
think he should be pronouncing about
whether this is language that's that's
reminiscent of Germany in the 1930s
because I don't think he knows and I
think increasingly we're hearing we sit
with Gary Neville on Sky he talks a lot
about Boris Johnson and and the Tories
uh footballers are just increasingly
feel they can get involved in politics
and actually generally people don't want
to hear about it from them it is a
really weird cultural phenomenon that we
have these footballers particularly
named Gary I think uh Gary Neville and
Gary lineker who are looked upon
increasingly by large ways of the
society as the voice of kindness and
moderation and yeah a lot of people
think Gary Neville was going to get
involved in politics I think Aaron
Neville is a is a is a in word indeed is
a natural Tory um I think he's too thick
to realize it he's claims himself
socialist he doesn't behave like a
socialist but you get people you get the
culture you deserve the people get the
coach to deserve and maybe we do deserve
to have uh footballers former
footballers as the the sages of our time
politically that's it for the view from
22 this week thank you very much for
watching before you go I'd like to
remind you that football is a very
simple game in which 22 men chase a
political football around the pitch and
in the end Gary lineker and his mates
always win
thank you
[Music]
foreign